so the newest resort on the strip opens
tomorrow night
and today we are getting our first look
inside resorts world bianca holman is
there live with the preview hey bianca
the north end of the strip of here on
las vegas boulevard has a new attraction
construction for a resorts world started
in 2015
may of 2015 and finally it's coming to
an end
it's been a long time in the works here
it's been a tough year on everybody and
we're really excited that
things are getting better and we're
excited about tomorrow night resorts
world is where the former stardust once
stood
as the world's largest hotel in 1958
this new property has more than three
thousand rooms and suites
it's actually three brands in one hilton
conrad and crockford
gary stefan from hilton brands says
there's something for everyone
every one of the hotels will have its
own independent identity
which is really critical when you're
putting a collection brand together
because you don't want to
standardize those every one of them
should have its own identity
but you know you're booking that ultra
luxury experience
and it's going to be brought to life in
a very las vegas
resorts world way every square foot is
unique from the casino floor to the
sportsbook inside a saloon
there's cashless gambling and with the
touch of a phone you can have grubhub
deliver a bite from one of the 40
food and beverage options on the
property the senior vp of operations
says they
plan to deliver what guests want as we
come out of
this pandemic i think there's two things
that everybody will want to do number
one they will want to go and see
families
and number two they will want to attend
live events we're talking about an
unprecedented lineup of headlining
residencies
celine dion carrie underwood katy perry
and luke bryan all have ink deals to
play the ultra high
tech 5000 seat theater the day
and night clubs will be busy as well
with big time djs such as tiesto
zed dj snake and others resorts world
will be the best in class
of everything
and for this opening weekend the resort
has enlisted the likes of paris hilton
and darius rucker to help open and
welcome guests and for fourth of july
miley cyrus bianca holman 8 news now